cause plenty to talk about in terms of
the brazilian variant but
you know we do like to mark the
milestones on this program and another
important one
has been passed 20 million people now uh
with the first
dose of the vaccine and some additional
funding to come
coming in soon to ensure that we get all
the way there to getting through the
adult population
or just as soon as possible really yes
uh neil it was an important moment
on sunday and i have to say credit to
the team
who don't have a sunday off they don't
have
any day off they just focus on
continuing to deliver
uh the vaccination rollout uh where over
20 million
people with the first dose and we're
seeing good early
uh efficacy data in terms of
both vaccines and also of course
good data from scotland from public
health scotland in terms
of both vaccines being effective against
severe illness and hospitalization
so we keep going we're focused on the
next
target which is the mid april target to
offer the vaccine
to 32 million people cumulatively that
is
everyone over the age of 50 and then we
go on to offer the vaccine
to all adults by the end of july and i'm
confident
with our supplies and the visibility of
deliveries
that we will meet those targets can we
though talk minister
um about this brazilian variant and just
before we get into the six cases that
we've identified here in the united
kingdom just how much do we know
about this variant of concern do we have
any indication
of what the effects of this variant are
in terms of transmissibility
in terms of what you just mentioned it
yourself vaccine
efficacy so in terms of its profile this
p1 variant is much closer to the south
african
variant which we've been dealing with
now for several weeks by
search testing genome sequencing and
isolation
we've had a few hundred of the south
african variant and this variant
is a variant of concern it's very
similar in terms of
uh its mutations to the south africa to
the uh
south african variant so uh it is
concerning uh there is one case uh
who the individual didn't fill in their
test card details so
we can contact them uh if they you know
they would probably got a home kit
or a test kit from their local authority
and what we're asking today is anyone
had
a test on the 12th or 13th of february
to contact
nhs 119 so we make sure we identify that
individual
and of course the two cases of south
gloucestershire
have been isolating uh one traveled
from south pole sao paulo through zurich
to london
uh before the hotel quarantine came in
but they did take a pre-departure test
and
filled in their forms the passenger
locator form which is why we're able to
deal with them so effectively and work
with south gloucestershire council
although there's minimal reason to
believe that
they may be further spread because they
have been isolating correctly
but we will be doing a somatic
asymptomatic testing
in south gloucestershire just in terms
of
of the effect on on south
gloucestershire itself of course
big day next week in terms of you know
the schools fully reopening
we understand of course what can happen
if more transmissible variants
get into places which serve as vectors
for transmission
is there a possibility that in south
gloucestershire we might not see the
schools reopening on monday
so the way we've been dealing with the
south african variant
this will be very similar in the sense
that we
search test um and we rapidly
isolate and of course gene sequence
what we've done with schools is
delivered 50 million uh
lateral flow tests so that secondary
schools
and the teachers in those second schools
are tested twice a week
uh there are four tests uh for the
students as well
uh before uh they the the
schools are able to obviously
fully um uh bring children back
to schools and and all that is taking
place uh
as we speak with teachers and i want to
just thank
obviously the teaching profession
they've been open all the way through
this second or you know this this spike
that we've had since december
because they've been teaching the front
line uh healthcare staff children and
those children that are most vulnerable
and the work they're doing is is
incredibly important
and i'm confident that we'll get all
schools reopened on the 8th of march
sure but but just in terms of this
brazilian variant and the way in which
it got into the country
we have known about its existence for
quite some time
we had advice from sage on the 21st of
january
that the only way to prevent new
variants from arriving here in the uk
was was to quarantine all the rivals
you know the quarantine system didn't
kick in until the 15th of february
isn't it the case that if the government
had been rather quicker
to introduce that scheme we might not
have seen the brazilian variant in the
community
well if you look at the two cases in
south gloucestershire
the case that came in uh from sao paulo
through zurich to
the united kingdom that case followed
exactly the correct procedure which is
the passenger locator form
a pre-departure test already conducted
and then
isolated as well so the uh
regime for our borders is pretty
uh stringent uh there are other
countries and
we can sort of discuss say for example
um
australia who have even more stringent
border controls but they still have
um variants uh occurring and have to
deal with them and the way we've been
dealing with the south african
various this was an indirect flight
wasn't it this was an indirect flight
and you know
we've won one we've been asking
questions about on this programme a
number of people
on the conservative benches the labour
benches have been warning about it as
well
i mean as things stand people from
brazil can still get to this country
on an indirect flight so people from
brazil are banned
from coming to this country even if it's
on an indirect flight if they are
uh uk nationals or residents then they
can they have to fill in a
passenger locator form which this
individual did they have to take
a pre-departure test which this
individual did
they then have to isolate for 10 days
and take two more tests
a test after two days and a test after
eight days
so three tests in total and i think that
system in itself is is robust which is
why we've been able to
locate uh these two cases and of course
the third is
is not linked uh to this but we we need
to identify them as well which is why
if you've had a test on the 12th or the
13th of february
and haven't had your result back please
get in contact with nhs119
i suppose the problem with all of this
minister is you know people were warning
about the vague porous quality at our
borders we had the health secretary on
the program on the 4th of february
and i said this when we were still
didn't have a date
for the quarantine hotels as things
stand with the controls we have at the
border with no date for the hotels
isn't it the case that there is a
possibility a new
potentially dangerous variant could
arrive here in the united kingdom
bypassing all of the security you've
mentioned mr hancock went on to say
you know we've got very stringent
measures in place the brazilian variant
got here
the stringent measures clearly weren't
enough
so that was what i was really trying to
get at when i mentioned the
uh australian uh border uh protocols in
regime or new zealand that people
often quite rightly refer to as sort of
your best examples of how to do things
they still have challenge challenges
with variants
actually getting in and they still have
to surge
test do the genome sequencing
and isolate in the way we've been doing
with the south african variant
i think if you look at this case
actually if anything it says
that our border uh controls are pretty
robust because the individual
did have a uh pre-departure test they
did have the passenger locator form
which is why we were
still and somewhere potentially in the
community yet to be identified
yes and and that's why we need to make
sure we we
uh find that individual and when we have
obviously um
data points that we're going to try and
make sure we locate them and of course
um the reason that we're asking the
media to help
is to if anyone has been tested on the
12th or 13th
of this month of february forgive me um
to come forward if they haven't had
their test results back because they the
one bit they didn't fill in
is their test card which has their
contact details
just in terms of what we're expecting
this week of course big week
for the chancellor and as always happens
you know we could spend you know 20
minutes speaking to you about
what's in the papers this morning and
we're all going to be told we have to
wait till wednesday so
just just philosophically as someone who
has a keen interest in business
what do you want to see from the
chancellor this week i mean
the oas oecd the world bank the imf
all suggesting that now is not the time
for for tax rises
particularly on businesses what's your
view of that
well i think it's important for all of
us to wait uh it's only another
48 hours um until the chances are is
on i'm on tenterhook's minister come on
well look i can tell you uh one thing
that i know the chance has been telling
business quite rightly is that our
strategy
for the recovery from this unprecedented
um challenger for the covert pandemic is
threated one
is infrastructure so a big focus on the
infrastructure bank and investing
you know big big amounts of uh billions
of pounds into infrastructure especially
green infrastructure the prime minister
in his ten point plan
set us a target that by 2030 every home
i will be powered by offshore wind um
so there's a big big push on
infrastructure the second is skills
and you look at the kickstart scheme 120
000
um uh places have been created for those
who are probably most vulnerable to the
covert
challenge the youngest people uh who are
in the on the employment ladder getting
on it sure sure
just in terms of the corporation tax
just in terms of the corporation tax and
i know you're not going to answer this
specifically i know you're not going to
answer this specifically
you get any number of companies at the
moment looking at whether or not to
relocate themselves
so that they have better access to the
eu market it's obviously happening
why would we give them another reason to
want to leave the country
in the form of a hiking corporation tax
well as i said look i can't comment on
uh any taxation
announcement as you can imagine uh not
least because they would be market
sensitive and of course
it's right that the chancellor delivers
his budget um as is traditionally done
uh on the third of march so not long to
go but what i would say
is that this country is eminently
investible you look at
uh in terms of of uh our
skills base our knowledge base we've
demonstrated it obviously through the
discovery of the vaccines and i think
this is a great place
uh to come and invest which is why we
still attract you look at fintech
financial technology we still attract
more investment in this country i think
than
uh the whole of europe um uh does
in in in fintech or at least we're on
the top uh before someone calls me up on
at the top of the league
in terms of attracting uh uh fintech
investment to the united kingdom so i'm
i'm
very confident that uh as we come out of
this covered
challenge the economy will will bounce
back and be incredibly dynamic
not least helped by rishi sunax budget
on wednesday